the lesson here for founders and i tell
this to founders don't do anything
that's close to the line
if he took 700 million out okay we would
all be like hmm
but you still need to make the 6 million
licensing the name to the company you
just took 700 million out
and do you really need the company to
pay you rent on buildings that's
such a bad look yeah it's the appearance
even if there's a reason and they gave
this whole convoluted you know they were
like well it increased to the
availability of space when no one else
was buying it and so he had to buy them
under his own and it was like
no no he didn't still know what he needs
to do is he needs to take this we family
of trademarks and he has to say you know
what
i did this and i realized this is
probably a mistake and the optics aren't
great
i'm going to gift it back to the company
and i'm going to give the company back
to 6 million
and then he should say you know the 700
million i have and all that stuff
you know i've thought i've given it some
thought and i am going to put myself up
in a twice as long lockup of the other
employees and investors to show i'm i'm
long this is what i would do that's
smart if i believe
those are actually very good ideas thank
you yeah well think i counsel companies
now foreign i didn't mean that
sarcastically yeah they actually
if he did those tomorrow it would be
materially good for the ipo
these would be intelligent things to do
yeah yeah so i don't know who's advising
him
but not i want to talk about that
because when we give founders now like
the industry of silicon valley has a
founder first focused now more so than a
used to
because founders now have more control
in investing uh it's a disaster
climates and so you can end up with the
founder having uh kind of voting control
even past an ipo we see this with
facebook it's worked out kind of
and this case hasn't worked out quite as
well do you think he just doesn't have
people around him adam newman that are
telling him this is a mistake because we
sit around here we look at this document
for five minutes and we're like pulling
our hair out going what is this
what are we looking at banana pants
banana pants i can tell you what happens
okay
uh when people get rich and powerful uh
like a number of friends who are
they the people around them who can tell
them the truth
that group gets fixed you mean set like
it's set okay
because when you're a billionaire
anybody you meet after getting rich
you can't trust their advice because
you're a billionaire now and they want
your money and they want your influence
and they want to stand next to you in a
picture
so they're left with a small cohort of
people then that cohort of people
will then some group of them will lobby
those people for money and try to you
know
uh trade off of their good name so then
the group gets reduced even further
and so if you have somebody like my very
close friends
travis elon chamath people you cover
the number of people who can tell
chamoth or elon or travis
i disagree with you on this one is small
and it's not that those people don't
want the candid advice it's that the
people on the other side are nervous if
if we're sitting here and the big boss
you want to tell them they're wrong it's
a very hard thing to do and
you have to as you go up the stack and
become more powerful
more influential or a billionaire um
you have to fight to get candid advice
and you are always wondering if you're
getting it and in this case
he's a narcissist right and a maniac
obviously
right who doesn't have good judgment
that's just plain and simple and best
case if you're in this scenario some
paranoia sets into all of your points
plus over time some paranoia sets in you
get this bunker mentality pretty soon
you don't think you trust the people
that you trust like you
torture your vizier with your dragon
boom yeah
and he yeah so he did not have a
foundation
that was strong enough to handle this
amount of power
this amount of privilege this amount of
money
and he just makes bad decisions and
somebody needs to just you know
if it was masi yoshi-san who put the
most money in
needs to get on a plane one of his plans
and just sit the kid down and say
i know i gave you all this money a b and
c
number one you're giving the trademark
or i'm out i'm selling my shares
the this which will collapse and tank
the company yeah says i'm out for this
behavioral reasons
it's over it's over and so that's what
needs to happen is somebody needs to put
their foot down with this founder and
say listen this is just bad optics
is it also possible that this founder is
in hundreds of millions of dollars worth
of debt
like i was sort of trying to do the math
here and i'm like even if he got paid
six million dollars and he got paid some
rent and whatever if he's taken out
it sounded like he has taken out
multiple loans
in the tens of millions two hundreds of
dollars
as his shares right so they're not
personal recourse loans so he can't lose
so you take
so he can't lose i see that okay it
could get problematic
right but here's he's not gonna have to
follow personal democracy so here's the
great rub
you're an average civilian you take out
a loan
mortgage bank loan whatever you're
personally on the hook you become rich
you got the stock offer equity you take
a loan against it you never have to pay
tax
it's a loan not only do you not have to
take tax
you might be able to get a tax write-off
for the loan not only
do you not have to pay tax now
you have that loan it's no not personal
recourse
you've put your shares up as the
recourse
i like really don't want to be a
personal citizen anymore kinda
yeah yeah yeah wow it's pretty crazy
right and none of this none of it no
still none of this falls under banana
pants sec rules still no
all fine it's all fine it's not the
sec's draw fine in america it's not the
sec's job to protect goldman
sachs it is their job to protect
civilians and make sure that things are
i mean
yeah i just think about a pension fund
eventually being invested in this
company and i'm like you know some of
them will be
yeah yeah no they don't necessarily have
to be there could be no appetite for the
stock when it goes public that's the big
and that's what i want to talk about
next what is the chance that this ipo
doesn't go out because they can't find a
price that the company is okay with and
the market is will accept is palatable
i mean i don't think this was a topic of
discussion before we saw the s1 but now
we've all seen it
i'm curious if anyone's willing to put
their foot in the water here and say
that it won't happen
i i don't know enough to really make a
call but i'm curious molly
i i mean i look at this and i'm like
there's no way this
could happen but apparently but a whole
bunch of things
have happened in just the last couple of
years that i never would have thought
would happen like
presumably someone still thinks that
there is money to be made here and if
there's any money to be made
why wouldn't it go forward um and just
wait
for the news about the wework summer
camp
to drop which wait this year's summer
camp
just all summer camps
that's see and there's a universe in
which that would be super smart
i mean why don't you dump this guy i'm
just gonna say you know what the summer
camp is like all the employees go
upstate new york and go crazy
i think you meant that they would
literally like buy space and then hold
summer camps there for like poor kids
because i'm a dumb dumb
no no they've had a summer camp for like
it would be awesome as if they
did my thing yeah exactly no it's not
something no
there's literally a summer camp that
occurs so imagine you had a
knife just imagine all right a world in
which twitter decided you know what
would be a really great idea
if we had all of our employees go up to
i don't know napa and we just created a
giant
like personal burning man to occur
inside of our company
from what i understand they've been
running a burning man of wework
and people come back and every year a
couple of people don't go back to work
this is what somebody an insider taught
oh dear god and that there's like this
huge liability of this like
it's like the ironically back to the
uber book it starts with that big x to
the x week that they did
or 10 to the 10 they did when they hit
100 million dollars and they did the
vegas week of parties and
yeah some like one guy called up two
prostitutes and he robbed them bla they
got rob blind and then they were fired
on the spot and it was i mean just like
on and on and on it's a pretty good book
actually you never
i mean in the old days everybody would
take their retreats in vegas and do all
this kind of stuff like microsoft
everybody would have these giant things
because you needed to have a stadium
that could fill
you know or halls that could fill tens
of thousands of employees that's when
you see
like uh those guys dancing on stage and
screaming developers like those are
almost dude
on youtube yeah those days are long over
i really want to start my version of the
company where we actually do like block
by block development like stadium style
and then also host summer camps for poor
kids yeah
i don't think no one's going to give me
money yeah i was going to say division
one's not calling you up
um okay well anyways i'm glad i'm not
alone that we were chaos because i i was
concerned that i was too stupid to
figure it out i was missing something
very important but it doesn't sound like
it so what
what to you